well you know during the pandemic so
many businesses had to shut down
except for those who were considered
essential and those essential businesses
stayed open but they had to figure out
how to do it safely and herrera family
dental is one of those businesses
started by a local las vegas who wanted
to invest in her community where she
grew up
dr herrera saw a lot of her own patients
but also many other patients who were in
true need of emergency help
when they were afraid to go anywhere
dr evelyn herrera worked hard to realize
her dream of being a dentist
her private practice in sunrise manor
was open
barely a year when the pandemic forced
her to close
we've always been trained to deal with
infectious diseases but i think
the unknown was more scarier than
anything and she worried for her
patients
their oral health so how long were we
going to not be able to see patients
because
they still need to be able to take care
of the oral health dr herrera was
forced to furlough all but one staff
assistant left to cover phones and help
her with emergency
cases patients who truly couldn't wait
for covid to be over
i was in excruciating pain my tooth
decided it wanted to hurt
it was march right at the very beginning
gloria long hernandez has been a loyal
patient for five
years seeing dr herrera in various
dentist offices
and now here at herrera family dental on
lamb and charleston
both share roots of growing up in east
las vegas when she started she told me
i want to help my community she says i'm
going to be a dentist not because
i want to you know she wasn't looking to
be wealthy she wasn't looking for all
these other things she was
literally looking to help the community
evelyn herrera's first language is
spanish
her hard-working parents immigrated from
mexico and made school a priority for
their kids
she received scholarships for college
then took out loans to attend unlv
dental school and with support from her
husband and daughter
she's sacrificed to create a successful
practice
i know some people think that it's a
rough area but it's only because it's a
little bit older but we do have a lot of
culture
in this community it would be nice and
this is one of the reasons why i came
back it would be nice to see more
businesses pop up herrera family dental
is open again with staff and coveted
safety restrictions still in place
i couldn't have felt more comfortable at
a time when everything was very
uncomfortable i think we did a lot for
their patients and i think they
definitely did appreciate it because a
lot of them still come here and dr
herrera hopes it's the beginning of a
very long relationship
with sunrise manor residents i want to
be that dentist that grows up with the
families that
how i saw my own personal dentist on the
east side
well dr herrera says that some of her
patients are still
scared to come back so she's giving them
plenty of time to feel comfortable
eighty percent of her patients speak
spanish
and so she has a a real
patient representation of the culture
the community here
and she says she feels wonderful to be
able to invest in this side of the
valley and she wish more businesses
would do that
because they really needed over here and
she said she was really happy to help at
a time when her community needed it
to keep people out of those crowded ers
and hospitals
last year during the pandemic and feels
proud of her staff
and that they feel like they made a real
difference and
she has a lot of pride in her business
so she's back open her staff is back to
work and
they feel like they made a great
accomplishment and they sure did in
their own community
alex john it's uh i've discovered a
whole lot about sunrise manor and the
sense of
neighborliness and and pride in their
community is probably
to the things that really stood out for
me in these last few weeks of producing
these stories
yeah and you found so many good nuggets
there sherry and so many really cool
people doing good stuff
in the community it's good to see